- This ain't Arby's, but we got the meats.
(big band music)
Hey, what's up?
It's Tway, and welcome to "Making it Big,"
the show where I take your favorite foods
and turn it into giant foods.
For this season, we are
actually filming everything
with a VR camera.
So if you notice that my
table is a little warped,
that's why.
You can watch the full VR episode
with a Meta Quest 2 in Mega Tasty.
That's our virtual cooking
world within Horizon World
or on Meta Quest TV.
So today I have a special guest
that you all know and love.
(regal horn music)
- I'm here, hello, hello!
- You guys, it is Rie, Queen of "Tasty."
I gotta admit, I'm kind of nervous.
- Oh, why?
- You are challenging me
because your taste is expansive,
and I don't know what you are
going to be challenging me to,
because you are kind of unpredictable.
- Well, you know I have a
show called "Make It Fancy,"
but you might be surprised
what I chose. (laughs)
- Okay, let's see.
- Tada!
- Korean cheese dog.
- Yeah, far from fancy,
it's a street food.
I'm new to Korean cheese dog.
- Yeah.
- But I love it.
So I just wanna eat more.
And why not make it big so I can eat more?
- Why not, right?
What is your favorite part
about the Korean cheese dog?
- You know, I'm a "Tasty" producer
and we love good cheese pull.
- Yeah, yes.
- So I expect you to do great cheese pull.
The stretch is from at least here to here.
I don't think I can do
it, but I believe in you.
I think you can do it.
Good luck, friend.
- Thank you.
Let's get to work.
(big band music)
So I have five pounds of
ground beef over here.
This is a pound and a
half of ground pork belly.
Gonna mix this up.
Oh hey!
Okay, well, Tiny Tway is
here and it looks like
she got sumpn' to say.
So let's hear it.
No way.
That long?
According to Tiny Tway, the corn dog
got really popular in Korea in 1980.
- [Official-Sounding
Announcer] In the 1980s.
- But it wasn't until 2016
where it gained its popularity
because they like basically
rebranded the corn dog
and added like the sugar and
the cheese and all the sauces,
and now it's literally
everywhere in the world.
So for flavoring, I have, I
think this is onion powder.
No, this is onion powder.
This is garlic powder.
This is white pepper.
Oh, don't breathe that white pepper in.
This is paprika.
And this right here is pink curing salt.
So what pink curing salt is is
just salt and sodium nitrate?
All right.
I like to feel it kind of like squeeze
through my fingers, and make sure
that every inch of this
meat is covered with flavor.
Oh, this meat smells seasoned.
Now I am ready to make this into a paste
because we're making a hot dog here.
(processor grinds)
Look at our beautiful paste.
Okay, that was only one batch.
I have this much left to do.
So be right back.
(easy rhythmic music)
This is not a hot dog casing,
because we can't find any
that's actually this big.
So this is like a, a casing for salami.
(casing crinkles)
Here we go.
What I gotta do is really
make sure (container taps)
that there are no air bubbles.
(container pounding on counter)
(casing crunches)
(more pounding)
I don't want (more
pounding) any air bubbles.
That's the enemy.
(ominous electronic chord)
(melodic electronic music)
So we've already tied the other end.
I'm going to, ugh- (laughs)
This is my foot long glizzy.
And this is going into the oven
for an hour and a half at 300 degrees.
This is going to cook the
hot dog and let it firm up.
So, be right back.
(relaxed retro music)
This is our boiled hotdog.
I'm gonna cut this side so you can see it.
(drum boings)
Children look away.
(sensual music)
(needle sliding on record)
Okay. So I actually need
to put this in the oven
at 500 for 15 minutes because
I want this to crisp up,
get a nice color going
because I mean, he's great,
but he could be better.
So let's make him better.
(rock and roll beat)
My meat is done. (sniffing)
It smells incredible.
Now we get to shave the
cheese nice and tight.
(driving rock and roll beat continues)
(funky sax joins music)
What we're gonna do is put this stick
through the dog, because this is going
to hold the cheese and the dog together,
but it's also like the stick
to hold the whole thing
together when you're eating it.
Here we go.
(music continues)
It went through!
I am going to actually
use these little skewers
to secure this to this
because it's so big.
I can't trust just one stick, you know?
(suspenseful music begins)
So I am going to secure it
with these stick right here.
All right, now time to put this together.
I-
Ooh
I need some help.
Beryl (echoes)?
(drum roll)
I'm gonna put my hand here to guide.
(drum roll continues)
(sticks crunch)
(funky organ music)
Time for the batter.
(music continues)
Oh hey, welcome back.
Okay, let's hear it.
So, according to Tiny Tway,
the difference between a Korean corn dog
and a traditional American corn dog
is that the batter for American
corn dolls have cornmeal,
but the Korean one does not.
So that's why there's no
cornmeal in this corn dog matter.
The more you know.
(ethereal musical flourish)
It's game time.
So I have to get the
glizzy coated in flour,
and then I'm gonna bring it over here
and batter it and then coat it in panko.
(playful music)
A little glizzy ASMR.
The tingles!
(playful, mysterious music)
Okay, welcome to the back kitchen.
Over there is my fry team.
Hi, fry team!
- [Echoing Announcer] Fry guys,
your guide to anything fried.
- All right, drop the glizzy.
(serious rock and roll music)
(lounge-style jazz music)
This glizzy is glorious.
It's looking beautiful.
Rie, are you here?
- I am here.
- [Tway And Rie] Wow!
- Oh my god.
You made a box too?
- Yeah, well I didn't make it.
- Okay.
- The art- (both laughing)
- Department.
- Oh! (laughs) Make it rain.
- Are you ready?
- Yeah, three, two, one.
- [Tway] We love good cheese pull.
Oh-
- Aah. (laughs)
Whoa. It's a lot of cheese.
- It's pulling.
- How about this?
- No, it's pulling.
(Rie laughs)
(cosmic music)
We love good cheese pull.(echoing)
I was gonna say, should
we put the toppings on?
(upbeat folk music)
- Okay, so I'm gonna do cross.
- This is very precious cargo.
There's a sriracha shortage.
- Oh my god.
- [Tway] Can we cheers?
- [Rie] Cheers.
Cheers to Tway.
(folk music continues)
Oh, it's yummy.
It's so good.
- I actually really enjoyed this
- Mm-hmm.
- [Tway] In the comments below,
Let me know what I should
make big next time.
- Peace.
- See ya.
(folk music continues)